well what we saw in New York with the
indictment of trump in regard to the
Stormy Daniels hush money uh payment
maybe just the beginning likely is just
the beginning of his legal troubles as
I'm sure you're aware and it could get
much worse very soon for him before we
dive into some reporting on this
something I've been talking about a good
bit on my show you can find that at Luke
Beasley on YouTube is while Trump should
be held accountable wherever he is
violated the law including the Stormy
Daniels case it's unfortunate that the
Stormy Daniels case being the less
significant one came first when we have
as we're about to talk about
a case where he could be held
accountable for attempting to overturn a
free and fair election pressuring
election officials the Brad
raffensberger call all those things and
that being one of the cases he's
involved in
one of the things he's being
investigated for makes the Stormy
Daniels case seem less significant
and so the fact that it came first is
unfortunate but we could be seeing the
more important one significant with huge
ramifications also coming very soon take
a look at this from The Washington Post
Donald Trump's appearance in a Manhattan
courtroom Tuesday marked a singular
moment in American history the first
time a former or sitting U.S president
has been indicted on criminal charges
but Trump's legal Peril is far from over
among those closely watching the
proceedings were state and local
officials in Georgia where Fulton County
district attorney Fanny T Willis is
expected to announce in coming weeks
whether she will file charges in
connection to efforts by Trump and his
allies to overturn the states 2020
presidential election results
expected to announce in the coming weeks
and we saw the media tour the grand jury
uh four person did
that was strange but it did reveal at
least in the eyes of the grand jury
likely charges indictments were
recommended and
if Fannie Willis follows in that path we
could be seeing charges very soon in
regard to what I see as the most
important thing Trump is being
investigated for if you somehow have
forgotten what this is all in reference
to or one of the elements of this
investigation here was the infamous
Georgia call or at least a part of it
so is this I just want to find
uh 11 780
votes so tell me Brad what are we going
to do we won the election and it's not
fair to take it away from us like this
and it's going to be very costly in many
ways and
I think you have to say that you're
going to re-examine it we have to stand
by our numbers we believe our numbers
are right Georgia has now
all I want to do is find eleven thousand
seven hundred and eighty votes I've
heard that so many times now
um but I
every single time I hear it
I
cannot process that that actually
happened and all that was surrounding
that it wasn't just him calling trying
to get Brad raffensberger to throw out
the election results and find 11 780
votes that didn't exist and Proclaim him
the winner it was also him coming up
with this alternate elector scheme
having a vice president at the time Mike
Pence
reject the actual elector's pretend fake
electors were the real ones and install
Trump the president throw us into a
constitutional crisis a coup
a a non-military coup was being
attempted there luckily didn't work but
he absolutely needs to be held
accountable and then a little bit here
from Yahoo news while Tuesday's
arraignment of foreign president Donald
Trump marked the first time a former U.S
president has had ever been charged with
criminal offenses it likely won't be the
last by summers in Trump could be
charged in no fewer than four separate
criminal investigations oh goodness
in fact while Trump's indictment
stemming from his 130 000 hush money
payment a thousand dollar hush money
payment to adult film star Stormy
Daniels represents a legal threat to the
former president The Others May carry a
greater risk of serious consequences
including a possible prison sentence as
most people recognize it's hard to
picture Trump being sent to prison
especially for these Stormy Daniels
case
but if we're going to see that happen or
at least him get house arrest
um
then I do think it'll come from one of
the other cases and of course you have
the federal investigation to his
mishandling and obstruction and regard
the documents classified documents you
have the federal investigation to
January 6 as attempts to overturn the
election you have the Georgia
investigation to his attempts to
overturn the election and then you have
the Manhattan district attorneys uh
investigation of the Stormy Daniels hush
money payment so a lot going on there uh
for Trump we have much more on the other
side of this break one of our sponsors
is electric e-bikes I've been watching
e-bike reviews on YouTube for a while
because I've been thinking of getting
one and I continually come across
electric as the brand to go with if your
budget is between 800 and 1300 and I
have to agree from experience I've had
my electric e-bike for a little while
now I've almost ditched my car and
regularly bike at this point for errands
and things around my neighborhood it's
awesome cardio because I'm still
pedaling I get there faster I can see
more I'm reducing my carbon footprint
the e-bike came to my doorstep fully
assembled it has a bright LCD screen
seven speed gearing five levels of pedal
assist a powerful battery that you can
take inside to charge it's also fully
foldable I can put it in the back of my
car electric has models for every
lifestyle and you can Finance for as
little as 73 bucks a month go to
electricebikes.com to learn more explore
all of the incredible e-bike models they
offer the link is down below